Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new thor 4 love and thunder video they're
getting ready to start filming the movie the
cast is all started showing up so we'll break
everything down all the easter eggs and all the
crossover with other big avengers characters and
marvel phase 4 movies if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
a bunch of big stuff coming up even Wandavision
episodes later this year will inform some of the
stuff that's happening during thor 4 we'll do a
new amazon giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and let me know which other
big easter eggs you want to see during thor 4.
i know everyone's asking for beta ray bill they've
been talking about him for a long time now so it's
just a matter of time before we see him show up
but number five recently you probably saw chris
hemsworth christian bale the rest of the cast of
the thor 4 movie showing up in australia the past
few weeks they've been doing pre-production for
a while some of the actors have been down there
longer but the cast has been talking about the
story there's a bunch of easter eggs and because
of what we know about the other movies in the
marvel disney plus series plots we now know
how some of the movies are going to be connected
and how the story will influence what's going on
during thor 4. this is them just posting joking
about doing the first read-through of the script
with taika watiti taking a nap in the middle
of the yard there that's just a joke about his
supposed legendary ability to take a nap anywhere
at any time under any circumstance just because
when you direct movies this big you typically
don't sleep for five months straight just because
everything's so non-stop but the movie did get
delayed because of the virus now it's coming
out february 2022 originally it was going to come
out november 2021 because all the thor movies have
come out in november so not a real huge delay the
eternals movie took its spot and yes for those of
you who have asked because the eternals in the mcu
are thousands of years old yes odin did know about
them thor also knows about them it's just that in
present day for pretty much what we've seen the
history of the mcu movies so far going back to the
first iron man film even captain marvel in the 90s
they've been relatively dormant not knowing about
their powers just living as normal humans amongst
them we'll probably get a trailer video for the
eternals movie when they get ready to release
the black widow movie and that'll tease some of
their history like they've been living among us
this entire time but because thor 4 is the next
movie right after the eternals movie yeah there'll
be some connective tissue maybe post credit scene
in the eternals movie for that just playing on the
idea that they both have these ancient histories
in the asgardians and the eternals go way back to
the dawn of civilization asgardians as a race
or a little bit older than the eternals though
at least in the mcu in the comics it's a little
bit different number four tessa thompson was the
one who actually confirmed that christian bale
would be their main villain there was a question
for a while as whether or not it was going to
happen he's being described as an intergalactic
villain so he's not someone from earth and
the most popular theories are that he's some
combination of gorr the god butcher and mangog
both butchers of gods the idea just being after
avengers endgame thor has stormbreaker he's like
the most powerful version of thor he's ever been
so who could threaten a legit god of the mcu but
a butcher of gods gorr is just a much more complex
interesting character and also if we're talking
about big comic book easter eggs from the thor
comics jason aaron created the gorr character he
also created the major comic book story line for
the jane foster thor that they're using for the
big twist of the movie number three the whole jane
foster thor announcement from comic-con last year
created a lot of confusion so here's the thing
chris hemsworth recently said that he's going to
do more marvel movies as thor as you know him for
the foreseeable future through avengers 5 whenever
that movie winds up happening just because so many
of the marvel movies have been delayed jane foster
thor isn't intended to replace thor it's just them
doing the big twist with odin's enchantment
whosoever holds this hammer if they be worthy
shall possess the power of thor like when captain
america was wielding mjolnir fighting thanos
for that brief period he was wielding the power
of thor himself even though they've been kind
of weird with the way they explain thor's power
like you technically use the hammer to channel
thor's power the hammer itself doesn't contain
the power of thor like the power was within thor
the whole time that was what the whole joke about
the god of hammers was from odin and thor ragnarok
so it's really like odin created a spell that
allows thor to share his power with other people
and it sounds like at least for now the
plan is the jane foster thor will just
be a thing for this one movie and then after
that she'll just go back to being regular jane
foster and chris hemsworth thor will continue
to be regular thor in bringing it back around
to Wandavision the darcy character who's sort
of like an assistant to jane foster's thor
is actually going to be working in the Wandavision
series they didn't say what she'd be doing but i'm
assuming she's connected to nick fury in the
sword agency natalie portman also mentioned
the cancer storyline from the comics so it
sounds like they're doing a version of that too
albeit somewhat deluded in the mighty thor comic
run when she was wielding the hammer she had been
suffering from a late stage for cancer and was
basically on her deathbed but every time she
activated thor's powers by summoning the hammer
the energy that she channeled was so great that
it actually burned through her life force even
faster so it actually killed her a little bit each
time she wielded the hammer but she kind of wound
up getting addicted to the thrill of being thor
like you do so she just kept on doing it and
doing it so number two where does that hammer come
from because the main mcu version of mjolnir was
destroyed by hella back during ragnarok every time
i talk about this there's always some confusion
in the comments notice that captain america takes
thor's hammer that he had stolen from the events
of thor the dark world when he takes the infinity
stones back so he's taking thor's hammer
back to where they took it from originally
so by the time they get to the asgardians of the
galaxy scene there is now no more mjolnir in the
main mcu anymore also remember that mcu thor is
still worthy so even if there had a mjolnir that
still existed he'd be able to continue dual
wielding just fine for the added attack bonus
and stormbreaker is supposed to be way more
powerful than mjolnir at least within the mcu
some people have wondered if thor is just going
to have the dwarves re-forge the broken pieces of
mjolnir because they made the first version
of the hammer why couldn't they do it again
but i think it'd be more interesting especially
if all the marvel phase 4 movies are rolling hard
on the multiverse twist that it would be way
more interesting to have jane foster thor wield
a version of mjolnir from the multiverse that also
helps explain the loki twist so for those of you
that were wondering taikawatiti confirmed that tom
hiddleston would be in the movie as loki he's like
we're not going to make a thor movie without loki
that'd be weird he didn't specify which version of
loki it would be but because all the disney plus
series are crossing over with the movies it's an
easy prediction to make that it would be the loki
from avengers end game who escaped created the new
timeline with the tesseract and is getting his own
disney plus series next spring it's going to be a
big time travel series with a bunch of time travel
villains the time variants authority captures him
forces him to work for them they're kind of
like the time cops or the time lords of the mcu
but because it's a loki from the events of
the original avengers movie he has none of
the memories of original loki after this so he
had none of that character development none of
those experiences with thor so he's going to be
a completely different version of the character
i'm gonna burn this place to the ground number
one so early theory christian bale's villain just
presents a challenge so overwhelming that one thor
even with stormbreaker isn't enough to stop him he
needs two thor's that's where you get to the jane
foster thor twist and then loki arrives from the
multiverse with another version of mjolnir
in tow and that's where you get her hammer
and if we're talking about multiverse here i know
a lot of you have asked about that scene of loki
wielding mjolnir because that's actually a deleted
scene from thor the dark world he's just imagining
himself wielding it they can actually do a twist
like that on the loki series if it's going to be a
big multiverse show they're actually going to be
doing multiple versions of loki from the comics
on that they're doing kid loki they're doing a
version of female loki maybe also a version of
older loki but they'll explain that when we get to
those episodes it's going to be a while before we
see a trailer for that though the whole thing with
the guardians of the galaxy though per vin diesel
is that they'll just cameo in thor 4 then Thor's
going to cameo in guardians of the galaxy vol
3 but it's mostly supposed to be minor cameos for
continuity just to address what thor's been doing
with them since avengers end game and then they'll
probably have a tag scene setting up guardians 3
the same way that thor was in doctor strange's
post credit scene then they just did a longer
version of that scene during thor ragnarok i have
been falling for 30 minutes there's going to be a
ton of avengers crossover happening in marvel
phase 4 movies i just did a video about doctor
strange showing up in spider-man 3. but really
important reminder Wandavision is actually the
first place where we'll see all that get set up
that's going to set off the big multiverse level
chaos twist that's going to inform a lot of the
plots of the marvel phase 4 movies scarlet witch
is going to cause a whole bunch of chaos and
they're going to feel the repercussions of that
in all the different movies so everyone let me
know in the comments what are you most hyped
up for in thor 4 post all your theories in the
comments and what's going to happen is tomorrow
my mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video is going
to post make sure you have alerts enabled for my
channel so you don't miss any of those episodes
all the wanda vision episodes are supposed to be
released after the mandalorian season 2 episodes
while you wait for everything click here to watch
tom holland hilariously try to spoil spider-man
3 and click here for that brand new mandalorian
season 2 trailer video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe this is the way!